salut c'est monsieur rossi vous parle du
webmail 20 light est ce que ça vous
parle c'est un smartphone de huawei qui
pourrait arriver très prochainement il
va y avoir d'autres modalités y avoir le
mail 20 et le médecin de pro qui va
arriver aussi et probablement un peu
plus tard lors d une fiche technique qui
est assez complète sur le net un light
on voit vraiment hein quoi il devrait
ressembler on a une petite idée de la
date de l'annoncé comme pour le pvp 20
tropez main lights est le modèle le
moins cher modèle le plus abordable et
ça justement je vous en parle
le may 20 mais devint mate mc 20 à la
française le web matin light pense que
la prononciation c'est plutôt le why we
made by night devrait arriver
prochainement devrait arriver après le
mail 20 et le may 20 promet ce mec 20
live pourrait pointer le bout de son nez
d'ici quelques semaines à l'ifa parce
qu'il faut savoir que huawei va faire
une conférence une pinotte ali farzat
représentait probablement plusieurs
choses à commencer par le kerry 980 qui
revient prendre la suite du kirin 970 1
kering 980 qu'il devrait gravé en 7
nanomètres un soft qui offrirait encore
plus de puissance à huawei pour ses
smartphones
il récupère la fin de l'année le mail
devaient-ils may 20 promet également
l'année prochaine le paie 30 petre en
pro ça pourrait être plutôt cool
et justement le mec va lite on a déjà
une débauche de fiches techniques eux il
a l'air franchement plutôt cool montre
avoir un écran de 6 points 3 pouces une
dalle ips lcd avec une définition de
2340 par 1080 pixels un format 19,5 9e
il devrait tourner sous un kirin 710
octas core cadencé jusqu'à 2,2 gigahertz
si giga de ram 64 giga de stockage
extensible avec une carte micro sd
jusqu'à 256 giga la puce graphique c'est
une malijai 51 mp4 il devrait avoir une
batterie de trois mille six cent
cinquante millions terreur et il
tournerait sous android
8.1 oreo au niveau du module photo on
devrait avoir un double module de
l'arrière et un double module à l'avant
pour l'arrière 20 mégapixels + 2
mégapixels le 2 méga pixels
ça revient à prendre effet de profondeur
en faire des photos avec cette fameuse
effet bloqué à l'avant capteur principal
de 24 mégapixels avec également 1,2
mégapixel toujours pour un effet bloqué
vous pourriez filmer en 1080p c'est à
dire du full hd à 30 images par seconde
à l'avant comme à l'arrière et il aurait
du bluetooth 5.0 voile un peu pour une
ébauche de fiches techniques autour de
ce mail 20 light
alors ce mec là est il destiné à qui il
serait destiné à un public qui veut un
smartphone huawei pas forcément pro cher
qui veut pas mettre de l'argent sur un
modèle standard ou sur un modèle
professionnel mais qui reste néanmoins
exigeant
niveau de la qualité de fabrication
sachant que le web permet quand même
d'excellents smartphone huawei qui est
d'ailleurs passé ya pas très longtemps
devant apple le faisant passer la passe
de troisième constructeur mondial à
deuxième constructeur mondial
j'imagine qu'à la fin de l'année ça va
s'inverser apple par repasser devant et
normalement sur une fin d'année apple
reprend lead et passe numéro un donc ça
c'est un jeu de chaises musicales
alors il va y avoir également le mec de
20 et qui devrait arriver et le mail
vendent pour alors il devrait arriver un
peu plus tard mais il ya pas mal de
choses sont connues sur la fiche
technique on devrait donc avoir le
fameux kirin 980 si giga de ram 128 jir
du stockage je suis pour rien à voir
aussi les points de différenciation soit
4 gigas de ram si j'irai peut-être même
eu 8 gigas de ram 128 go de stockage 256
512 il pourrira effectivement plusieurs
versions une batterie aux alentours des
4010 empereur une recharge sans fil qui
dit recharge sans fil didot envers un
écran de 6 5 3 pouces pour le mettre 20
c'est l'écran cdu amoled et un écran de
6 à 8 9 pouces pour le mettre 20 pro
c'est à dire vraiment quelque chose de
énorme pour le modèle fraude il va
risquer leurs empreintes digitales
directement intégré à l'écran et il
tournerait sous android 9.0 paix avec
une surcouche le m8 9.0 et je vous dis
il devrait être présenté au mois
d'octobre novembre pour une sortie fin
d'année bien évidemment vous inquiétez
pas parce que tout ça on va reparler
très très prochainement
l'ifa je vais aller me promener un peu
partout on va aller voir ce qui se passe
on va aller découvrir un peu s'il est
des nouveautés qui sort tout va bien
évidemment les prendre en vol lorsque je
vous invite à faire c'est à vous abonner
à rester connectés
parce qu'on va aller voir ça directement
ensemble et ce quelques temps non plus
d'aller voir ça va coïncider au niveau
du lancement du nouveau format pour la
rentrée saison 2 qui va débuter à partir
de 1er septembre une vidéo par jour en
continu
un format revue améliorer corriger
d'ailleurs si vous avez des suggestions
en faire vous pouvez les poser
directement en bas en commentaire merci
à vous d'avoir regardé cette vidéo
j'invite comme dame a blessé des jolies
pousse à rester connectés je suis comme
giuly va y avoir plein de nouveautés
et plein de choses des textes des exclus
des guides des tutos enfin et dans le
vent de choses si vous avez des envies
en particulier une fois de plus vous ne
les marque est directement pas je vous
dis à très bientôt vous embrasse soyez
sages et à bientôt ou ciao
[Musique]